hey so I'm pretty cast ready and as I
just wrote in my blog post I'm starting
my first year pretty series and the
whole idea is that I've gotten a lot of
emails from programmers who are kind of
learning the code and they're trying to
break into and get their first jobs or
really just try to learn to code and
they have a lot of questions or doubts
along the way and and I'd love to kind
of take the time out of my take some
time every week to kind of answer some
of these questions that I think are very
very common questions I get and I think
I can give you my best advice based on
the experience that I've had kind of
breaking in and out into the world of
being a developer right so this week I
got a question from a girl and what
she's asking was she said I'm really
keen on getting some reaction experience
but anywhere I applied to they seek an
experience react engineer I have learned
reacts to my own and recruiters don't
seem to appreciate it further at this
stage I pick at the big companies I
reach one or two rounds behind the final
round and then they say they found a
more experienced person for this role
recently I got a rejection from company
X and company Y they both required five
to six years of industry experience my
application took me to the initial
rounds and they seemed interested in
gauging my potential only to find that I
was not as good as someone they were
looking for next week I'm going to
another full stack ball at company C but
it's clearly out of my league they're
seeking at least six years of experience
in JavaScript I'm pursuing it honestly
for the interview experience and maybe
who knows what if it works out somehow I
don't know many people who can who can
refer me to these jobs either so how do
I get my first reactor without
experience I totally empathize with this
issue ah and I have been interviewed and
probably a little bit over over a year
for an engineering role but I was just
curious and I kind of Rani's and I went
to look at the descriptions of some of
their job postings and so for example
there's one on Facebook where they're
looking for Instagram software engineer
and graphics I'm scrolling down into the
minute into the qualification section
and yes it definitely says you know a BS
or master's degree in computer science
it says five plus years of professional
experience
interactive computer graphics using C or
C++ a bunch of other requirements so
definitely they have the years they're
listed another roll at Facebook is a
software engineer full stack and look at
the minimum qualifications it says BS or
MSN electrical or computer science two
plus years of relevant work experience
so yeah again they list they want some
kind of work experience here to another
one I went to was Netflix what's funny
about Netflix is they don't really have
anything but senior software engineering
roles on their website so the senior
software engineering law partner
engineering it says ESRB in computer
science five plus years of experience in
software development um so again another
company that shows year of experience um
let's see I also went to LinkedIn I'm
looking at their software engineer
performance mobile or web this is
probably the most daunting job
application I've ever seen
so many requirements makes my head spin
okay one you plus year of experience in
mobile web one plus years of experience
in software design development algorithm
related solutions one plus year of
experience in programming and object
oriented language two plus years of
experience in mobile web or browser
performance engineering C yes again they
list years of experience that they're
looking for then I decided to go and
look at some earlier stage companies one
is a firm and their application doesn't
have any years of experience listed
which is cool and it looks like you know
they're kind of looking for passion and
drive someone who's fluent in fun and
web technologies comfortable finding
their way around back-end API but
nowhere does it list years of experience
interesting um another startup I went to
as a company called data breaks I'm
looking at their full and it looks like
they too don't have a minimum
qualifications or anything it just says
someone who can you know develop HTML
CSS and JavaScript good communication
skills etc so interesting
it looks like some of the bigger
companies listed years of experience
while some didn't but I'd have no surge
to figure out like what kind of
companies list years of experience and
what don't
but overall um it's definitely clear
that there's a lot of companies that
explicitly state the number of years of
experience and honestly sometimes you're
looking at these requirements and you're
like this makes my head spin right like
I totally understand your pain some of
these applications sometimes can be
extremely daunting because they make it
look like there's looking for someone
who almost has superhuman capabilities
um but you've probably been coding for
like what a year maybe two years maybe
even less and you really need that first
job just like prove yourself right um I
can't give everyone like blanket advice
but I'll tell you how I approached it
when I was looking for a lot of
something said like X years of
experience it didn't mean that I didn't
apply right I'll typically look at the
requirements and and and kind of that
what the job application said and give a
sense of what they're seeking I would
try to evaluate whether I can honestly
fulfill those requirements for example
in the first Facebook one where they
were looking for five plus years of
experience in computer graphics clearly
I don't have five plus years of
experience in computer graphics I don't
even have one year experience in
computer graphics in fact I don't think
I've ever worked on computer graphics so
I wouldn't apply for that but the second
Facebook role with just software
engineer at just a full-stack software
engineer even though it says two plus
years of relevant work experience the
rest of the bullets I feel like I can
fulfill and even if I don't know
everything today I'm confident I can
learn it on the job if I need it to so
uh that's kind of how I would devalue
whether I make it make sense for me to
apply or not um and if I'm confident I
can fulfill those roles and I would
apply and also one thing I've noticed
pretty frequently when I was applying
was that a lot of this senior a lot of
the roles at the said like senior they
they must have meant someone who could
do the work without needing a lot of
help
maybe not needing a lot of mentorship
someone who can like kind of just run
with a stand on their own feet and beard
and think through these problems
themselves and if you think you kind of
made that go ahead and apply who knows
maybe you'll get the
get an interview right and again it's
just important to be reasonable if they
say five plus years and C++ experience
if you've never written a line of C++
then don't apply there's no need to
waste your time and their time with that
application just be honest with yourself
when you're applying and another really
great way to get in the door is get
referrals I found this to be incredibly
helpful and in fact there was a lot of
times where I would get a referral into
a company and even though they didn't
have the job listing for me on the on
the jobs page they would they would
still give me a phone screen at least
because because you know referrals go a
long way someone is out there watching
for you and saying hey I know prithi I
think she's awesome I think she's smart
I think she's capable so I'm referring
you to this company they're putting
their their name in front of you and and
they're willing to do that for you so
the company kind of takes that as
positive reinforcement they're like okay
so she got a referral so maybe it's
worth kind of bringing her in and seeing
what she's got right and another thing
that I found really helpful personally
was kind of showing them that even
though you don't have those years of
experience what have you done outside of
work right this can be things like you
know making sure that you get her
profile looks good like do you have side
projects that you're really proud of
maybe make the public so that someone
who's a recruiter or manager can go onto
your github profile and see what you've
been working on another great way is
contributing to open source even if it's
just documentation whatever it is any
kind of small contribution to make to
open source goes a long way it shows
what you're capable of and shows your
involvement in the community and your
passion for programming um another
really great way that worked for me is I
love writing and I started writing
pretty early my programming career and I
used writing as a way to explain
concepts that I was learning and so that
really helped me in my job process for
sure people would kind of run across my
blog and see that hey like even though
she doesn't have experience she she
knows what she's talking about right and
so the idea is that even though you
don't have the experience to show them
somehow figure out a way that to show
people that you're really capable and
you have the potential to
those requirements and so you apply and
if you get a response Congrats that's a
huge step right the first thing you
difficult point is a good phone screen
and from my personal experience I've had
a lot of people use this phone screen to
kind of ask me to quantify what
experience I've had in the past and I'd
be honest I'd talk about my side
projects
in depth again you know like you know if
you don't have experience don't talk
about what you don't have talk about
what you have because because then you
can kind of really show them that even
though you don't have that work
experience you've done a lot of
programming on your own right and again
things like side-project open source
projects blog post these goes a long way
to fill in the gaps for the experience I
think that you don't have and once you
get past that phone screen at this point
the ball is really in your court
there are way any doubts that you had
along the whole application process
about your ability to perform when you
apply just throw it all out because
you're really in the driver's seat at
this point the company what if they've
given you their first interview they've
indicated that they think you have
potential to fulfill the role look they
get hundreds maybe thousands of
applications and they chose you and
they're saying okay this person I think
he or she has potential and now it's
really up to you to prove that you you
do have potential and that you're
capable full from the role and I often
found that the best way to kind of
prepare for this was you know reaching
out to the recruiter and asking her like
I met her like really bugging them about
the role like what is a tech stack
what's your role going to be like what
are you can expect it what are you going
to be expected to do and build what's
the cultural life what are the key
skills are going to be testing and
looking for what's the interview style
like is it like a whiteboarding
interview is it like a practical
take-home interview is it a mix of both
like don't ever be surprised about the
interview really anything that the
recruiter is willing to share with you
and just like use all that information
to prepare as much as possible and I can
go I probably can go talk about the
preparation process in another video but
the main point I want to get across is
like even though the application might
have said X
years of experience if you've gotten the
interview then then the ball is 100% in
your core and you really have to use
this opportunity short of everything you
got because they've kind of put their
truck by giving you an interview they're
like okay I think she has potential he
has potential um and now it's your job
to kind of prove that to them and
honestly just be honest with what you
can do and what you can't do and if you
don't know something the best you can do
is tell them that you don't know it but
should tell them that you have Oh show
them somehow that you have potential and
that you're excited to learn are you
capable of learning that even though you
don't know this that you'll you'll
you'll sit there and you'll figure it
out because honestly no programmer knows
everything right like everything every
programmer is learning almost every
single day learning something new and
and they're really looking not looking
for someone who knows everything under
the Sun but they're looking for someone
who knows a good amount but you know if
they're throwing something you don't
across a problem or faced with some kind
of debugging issue they can figure it
out they can learn they can they can
grow that's kind of the people that's
kind of the people that a lot of these
managers are looking for to hire and
even if you don't get the job because
you know you don't meet some you don't
have the experience or because some
other senior engineer got the job over
you really don't waste this opportunity
use it as an opportunity to get candid
feedback ask the company hey like I know
that you know you hired someone else
because they had more experience where
could I have improved where the
variables I'm missing experience was in
my should I learn more about databases
was it my computer architecture
questions was more my algorithms and
data structures like where was I lacking
the experience and what can I do better
next time because you never want to make
the same mistake again
right and you always want to focus on
improving some of the weaknesses that
you have don't focus on what you already
know really really well for the
interview just focus on for the next
interview making sure that you improve
on what they told you you could have
been proved on and honestly if you got
an interview for a job that said five
plus years of experience and you have no
experience that's pretty awesome let's
admit it you were basically competing
against senior engineers and experienced
engineers so use it as an opportunity to
grow and learn and and really just
experience the process of interviewing
for some more advanced roles and kinda
conclude um I totally get that getting
your first gig is almost the most
hardest one and most frustrating one I
went through this process myself and I
was honestly pretty shocked but by how
difficult the process is and I totally
get it and in fact my little sister is
going through that process right now and
it's been taking her a few months what I
often found is everyone kind of wants
you to come back next year when you have
a little bit more experience and you're
like sitting there going well like where
the hell am I supposed to experience
from if you can't give me the chance to
get get this experience and I trust me
like I know that feeling but this for
your first job particularly keep
persisting keep applying keep looking
let people know around you that you're
looking for a job and just use every
interview as a learning opportunity
sometimes the whole process takes weeks
sometimes it takes months sometimes it
might even take a year but once you land
a first gig it's you you're kind of the
next one gets way way easier so work
really hard for your first one and in no
time you'll have your first job alright
I'm done